what's popping variant it's me Mt and
welcome back to the heavy spoiler show
and oh my god there goes Loki time
slipping again Loki episode 5 was such a
great look into just how much Loki's
true enemy throughout his life has been
his own crippling loneliness and also
just how much his brief new connection
to his new friends at the TVA has
changed him from being an agent of chaos
to a defender of order but how exactly
were those friends the key to his newly
mastered time slipping abilities and how
could the answer to that tie into the
actual orange and green color scheme of
the TVA and the entire Loki season 2 in
general let's talk about all that
together right now my nerd babies all
right so when Loki realizes that he
doesn't not exist after the sacred
timeline had a big old fart he starts
time slipping first time slipping after
he says hello to himself only to become
the very same version of Loki that he
says hello to then he Time Slips to
Casey's true life on the timeline as
alcatra prisoner Frank Morris before
realizing realizing that Frank can't
help him which then leads him to time
slipping to sylv's McDonald's then Don's
jety Emporium and then the time theater
where Loki first met Mobius then B1 15's
hospital as Varity Willis and then to
ob's life as the greatest author of all
time ad Doug and so on and so forth now
there is an obvious trend to all of this
the reason why Loki jumps through time
and space in this order is because Loki
is thinking about his friends that is
literally the secret to Loki time
slipping and it's a science that we've
seen in practice in the MCU before
specifically in Spider-Man no way home
when Ned Leeds uses his inner orange
magic energy inside of himself to
connect with Peter Parker but instead of
connecting with 616 Peter Parker Ned
accidentally found the Ry Universe Peter
and The Amazing Spider-Man universe
Peter it was Ned's love for his best
friend that caused the sling ring to
find Peter Parker just not the right two
Peter Parkers like Ned did not have a
particular location in mind when using
his inner magic it just locked onto the
variant of the person that he was
connected to and wishing for right away
this is what I believe to be one of the
main powers of the orange Soul energy in
the MCU in general the power to connect
to other people especially the people
close to you and this orange energy is
just one of these six main rainbow
energies that lives inside every single
living being in the Marvel Universe to
make up their total tempor Aura
otherwise known as their life essence or
if you're fancy your inner Chi a concept
that we see exemplified best during Wen
Wu's death scene in shanqi specifically
when wenwu gives shuni the 10 rings as
the rainbow of various Infinity energies
that made up wwu's total temporal Aura
got eaten by the dweller in darkness
mostly because wenwu was a big old
Dingus who thought his wife was talking
to him if you notice as soon as those
Rings attached themselves to shangi they
glow with an orange color as those Rings
channel the very same type of orange
Soul energy that the Sorcerers of comage
source for their magic it's basically
why anybody who walks through the
ancient ones doors willing to learn can
discover how to wield their own inner
bright orange Soul power to help defend
their reality from the forces of
primordial Darkness like doramu and such
and also how Doctor Strange was able to
use that weird green magic that we see
him use in Multiverse of Madness while
fighting that big eyeball monster he was
simply manipulating his own Infinity
energies inside to create Magic that's
all magic is in the MCU the infinity
energy from The Big Bang that lives
inside every human being as the rainbow
soup that is their temporal Aura this is
why the sacred timeline itself is just a
big ass band of rainbow energy because
every reality has been forged by the
same Big Bang Infinity energies that
made the Infinity Stones as mere
byproducts of an explosion of
insurmountable energy a similar Big Bang
to what we witnessed at the end of Loki
episode 4 I made a really fun video
about that that you can find here check
it out it's really great #the Marvel
trigger Theory It Is by accessing and
manipulating one's temporal aura that
allows things like orange sorcery or
blue Witchcraft and other superpowered
Marvels to happen in the MCU but on top
of this much like Rocket Raccoon
explains to The Avengers in Avengers
endgame massive explosions of big bang
temp peal Ora energy have happened
repeatedly on MCU Earth due to Thanos
and Tony's infinity stone snaps which
have likely led to the rise of mutant
Marvels in Phase 4 and Beyond it is this
Infinity energy that is responsible for
all the superpowered in the MCU now
the reason why I am saying all this is
because in the MCU the soul energy
Singularity is deeply connected with the
lives of other people and the reason why
the main upper levels of the TVA itself
are themed or orange colored is because
the TVA used to manipulate the flow of
the Sacred timeline by specifically
manipulating the fates of human Souls
through the use of orange time doors
that allow them to move around the
Multiverse much like mordo tells his
students of kerage how orange sorcero
portals can potentially allow for travel
throughout the Multiverse in Doctor
Strange 1 by monitoring every decision
that everybody makes in harnessing the
power of MCU Soul Singularity energy
through tempat technology the TVA was
able to weave time but why why should
the actions of living beings like humans
or Gods even matter to a omnipotent
Force like the TVA I mean living beings
aren't the only elements in the universe
right what's so special about souls that
is so Centric to the TVA well and simple
really time itself is measured through
the lens and experiences of living
beings time has always been relative to
our lives I mean hell there wouldn't
even be time in our real Universe if it
wasn't for the human need to keep track
of the past and future in order for
society to learn and evolve a planet
full of freeth thinking and free moving
beings makes more of a mark on the fate
of the universe than like a dead planet
with nobody on it due to an apocalypse
or something which is why Sylvie found
Refuge from the TVA hiding alone in the
shadow of oncoming apocalypses because
if there's no one around to do anything
in the near future then there's no
measurable time for the TVA to
manipulate but anyways this all being
said ad Doug Compares Loki's time
slipping powers to the temp pads of the
TVA for that specific reason because
Loki's time slipping is just as Soul
Centric as the orange portals of
sorcerers or even the temp pads of the
TVA and much like the Ancient One forced
Doctor Strange to surrender his ego and
his need for control at the top of Mount
Everest in order to teach him how to
master the art of creating a portal it
wasn't until the two reality ending
events of Loki episode 4 and Loki
episode 5 that Loki was forced to let go
of his own perceptions and
understandings of how time slipping
could work and instead focus on what
matters to him the most on a deep
emotional level his friends Loki's love
for his new TVA friends and the memories
that came with those friends are the
source of Loki's new time slipping
Powers if Loki was still the same lonely
ass that he was before he stole
that Cube during the 2012 time highest
then there would have been no way
possible for him to have survived the
explosion of the timeline and the
subsequent unraveling of reality his
friends were his Beacon just like living
Souls have always been the beacons by
which the TVA has conducted their
business for eons but if the upper
floors of the TVA with all the TVA
analysts and hunters in it are themed
orange after the Soul Stone energy that
lives in the temporal Aura of every
living being then what about the lower
levels of ob's research and advancement
Department being themed Green Well much
like the green infinity Stone this is
the Loki production's way of symbolizing
how the RNA department is Centric to the
maintenance of the Sacred timeline
itself time because while the hunters
and analysts upstairs direct and shape
the flow of the Sacred timeline by
pruning Souls OB and Miss minutes were
downstairs making sure the actual
timeline that the TVA was molding was
being preserved because without ob's
influence there would be no timeline to
even prune to use the tree pruning
metaphor that the show has established
if the orange people upstairs are the
Multiverse tree branch pruners then the
green RNA Department downstairs with ob
is the one that Waters the plant and
makes sure that the tree grows healthy
the research and development department
of the TVA is the true time Department
of the TVA as we can see through just
how lost and oblivious all the analysts
were upstairs when all the glitches in
the TVA started happening in season 2
but this orange and green theme isn't
just limited to the function of the TVA
it's actually all over different scenes
throughout the show especially scenes
between Loki and Sylvie two characters
that the Loki production specifically
went out of their way to theme after
these two different infinity colors with
Loki being themed green and Sylvie being
themed orange and the reason why I
believe marble chose to do this was to
symbolically represent what these two
different Loki variants stood for this
season with the green Loki on the side
of preserving the order that the TVA
timeline provided the Multiverse whereas
the orange theme syv was more concerned
with giving all the souls of the
Multiverse the free will to make any
damn choice that they wanted without
fear of being pruned by the orange
Hunters of the TVA the time variance
Authority has always been about souls
manipulating souls in order to alter the
direction and the flow of time and the
cinematography of the show chose to
reflect that with the two specific
colors of the soul and time Infinity
Stones and that is why the who matters
most when it comes to Loki's time
slipping and why the word who is circled
repeatedly on that posted note as a way
of foreshadowing what Loki discovers
about his powers by the end of the
episode like this is genius in
storytelling in my opinion hats off to
all the set designers and the
cinematographers of the show because
they truly went in with the symbolic
intention 10 out of 10 no notes but
anyways thank you guys so much for
watching this video you can follow Me @
Mass entertainment on Twitter and
Instagram if you guys want to see me
post some really ridiculous but
most importantly please follow heavy
spoilers here on YouTube and wherever we
are in the internet because we got some
really great stuff for you all the time
and you don't want to miss it if you
liked the video feel free to give it a
like and if you really like the video
maybe consider subscribing we'd love to
have you but again thank you guys so
much for taking the time to watch this
video I love and appreciate you guys so
much please stay safe and please
remember to be kind to one another
because the world is really shitty right
now and we need kindness so please have
compassion to your fellow nerd all right
let